Sex im Weltall ist eine ziemlich
komplizierte Sache in unserem letzten
Video zu dem Thema ging es vor allem um
die aktuelle Forschung in diesem Gebiet
unsere Psyche und warum Sex tatsächlich
wichtiger für die Raumfahrt ist als man
vielleicht denkt in diesem Video hier
gehen wir aber noch einen Schritt weiter
in die Biologie genau gesagt was
passiert eigentlich nach besagtem Sex
kann man ein Kind im Weltraum kriegen
und wenn ja was passiert dann wir haben
recherchiert um die Frage zu beantworten
wie sehr ein menschlicher Alien aus
bevor wir loslegen ein wichtiger
Disclaimer dieses komplette Video ist
als Gedankenexperiment gedacht wir
versuchen natürlich alle Vermutungen
möglichst von dir zu treffen deswegen
haben wir auch wie immer alle Quellen
unten in der Videobeschreibung
aufgelistet trotzdem wird das hier alles
ziemlich spekulativ denn wie wir schon
in unserem ersten Teil erzählt haben es
gibt eben noch nicht so viel Forschung
im Bereich menschliche Fortpflanzung im
All ein weiterer Grund warum man hier
mehr Wissenschaft betreiben sollte
gedanklich setzen wir aber trotzdem mal
dort an wo wir beim letzten Mal
aufgehört haben nämlich bei der
Befruchtung
denn was ist schon gab sind zahlreiche
Tierversuche zum Thema Fortpflanzung und
hier scheinen den Menschen bei der NASA
wirklich nicht die Ideen auszugehen wenn
es darum geht irgendwelche Viecher in
die Flitterwochen zu schießen Ratten
Fische oder auch Seeigel okay die
allerersten in Mikrogravitation
geborenen spacebabys stammen allerdings
von einer Kakerlaken Dame namens najay
Star sie wurde 2007 an Bord des
russischen Photon M3 Satelliten in den
Orbit geschickt und brachte dort 33
gesunde Nachkommen zur Welt bzw zum all
man muss allerdings auch nicht immer
Tiere direkt ins All befördern in der
gravitationsbiologie nutzt man für sowas
auch sogenannte
3d-klinostate das sind quasi
dreidimensionale Zentrifugen die durch
sehr schnelles drehen und
Richtungswechsel einen ähnlichen Zustand
simulieren sollen wie in
Mikrogravitation in ein solches Gerät
hat man zum Beispiel auch Ratten
Spermien und Eizellen gesteckt bei
dieser künstlichen Befruchtung in
simulierter Mikrogravitation sind zwar
gesunde Würfe entstanden allerdings war
die Geburtenrate geringer als in der
Kontrollgruppe und auch bei anderen
Tieren zum Beispiel bei unseren Lieben
Seeigeln stellt man fest dass Spermien
weniger mobil sind und unzuverlässiger
befruchten warum genau ist aber noch
nicht ganz sicher jetzt ist natürlich
die Frage ob sich diese Ergebnisse
überhaupt auf komplexere Lebewesen wie
den Menschen und auf echte
Mikrogravitation übertragen lassen es
gibt allerdings gute Gründe zu vermuten
dass vor allem Strahlung ein Problem
sein wird wenn diese das Erbgut in
unseren Geschlechtszellen angreift und
die Probleme hören nicht bei der
Befruchtung auf sondern ziehen sich auch
in die Schwangerschaft
ein Heranwachsender Fötus reagiert sehr
empfindlich auf äußere Einflüsse
insbesondere Nervengifte wie Nikotin
oder Alkohol sind extrem schädlich und
im Zweifel sogar tödlich für das Kind
gut nur dass beides an Bord der ISS
verboten ist wovor die Raumstation
allerdings nur bedingt schützen kann ist
auch hier wieder Strahlung zwar gibt es
Schilde die herumschießende Teilchen
abblocken trotzdem sind Menschen auf der
Raumstation über mehrere Monate hinweg
gerne mal der 250-fachen Menge an
Strahlung im Vergleich zu Erde
ausgesetzt das hat im Zweifel ernsthafte
Gesundheitsfolgen Schäden an den Augen
am Herzen am Gehirn vor allem aber auch
die generative Krankheiten und die
Beschädigung der DNA die wiederum zu
Krebs führen kann all diese Dinge die
schon Erwachsenen Probleme bereiten
könnten in einer Schwangerschaft zu
erheblichen Komplikationen führen aber
das ist nicht alles ein weiteres Problem
hat mit der Orientierung zu tun ohne
Schwerkraft ist es natürlich schwierig
unten und oben zu unterscheiden vor
allem für einen Fötus kurz vor der
Geburt ist es aber extrem wichtig dass
der Fötus richtig bzw falsch herum im
Mutterleib liegt die Frage ist ob das
überhaupt noch richtig funktioniert wenn
die Schwerkraft nicht mehr vorgibt wo es
langgeht dazu können wir allerdings
keine wirkliche Antwort finden aber gut
selbst wenn das so wäre dann müsste man
eben auf Kaiserschnitte zurückgreifen
die er zum Glück heutzutage eine Option
sind tatsächlich gibt es aber noch einen
anderen Grund warum Kaiserschnitte
wahrscheinlich die natürliche Geburt
ablösen werden kommen wir also zu der
Geburt bei einer Geburt steht man
natürlich auch im All direkt vor der
größten Herausforderung wie versichere
ich mein Kind und welche Versicherungen
greifen denn bitte überhaupt im all-
oder auf dem Mars naja aktuell sieht es
dann noch schwierig aus zumindest für
Menschen denn Raketen und Satelliten
sind im All schon immer versichert wenn
es Krankenversicherungen im All dann
doch mal geben sollte dann haben wir was
für euch Clark Clark kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon in der App könnt
ihr ganz einfach alle eure
Versicherungen zusammenführen und
verwalten wenn ihr Clark benutzt dann
schließt ihr einen maklermandat ab Clark
wird dann quasi euer persönlicher
Versicherungsmakler so kann Clark für
euch die besten Angebote heraussuchen
und euch passende Vorschläge machen
welche Versicherungen für euch noch Sinn
machen und wo Ihr sparen könnt das ist
dann ähnlich wie wenn ihr euer Auto in
die Werkstatt gebt und der Mechatroniker
euch nach dem Check anbietet die Bremsen
neu zu machen weil es sonst beim
nächsten mal teuer und bis dahin
gefährlich werden könnte wenn ihr aber
schon einen guten Makler habt dann ist
klagt vielleicht aktuell doch nichts für
euch denn euer altes Mandat wird bei der
Unterschrift gekündigt aufpassen falls
Sie jetzt eure Versicherungen optimieren
wollt dann gebt bei der Registrierung
den Code Watson ein und bekommt für jede
Versicherung die ihr schon habt sogar
noch einen 15 € Gutschein für z.B
Cyberport den App Store oder Amazon das
geht für bis zu drei Versicherungen so
wo waren wir noch mal stehen geblieben
ach ja die Geburt von alien Babys an
sich sollte hier die fehlende
Schwerkraft kein Problem sein weil der
Körper das meiste sowieso mit Hilfe von
Muskelkontraktionen und Druck löst man
könnte allenfalls wieder das Problem
anführen dass Menschen in der
Schwerelosigkeit ihre Muskeln trainieren
müssen damit diese nicht abgebaut werden
das ist natürlich umso schwieriger bei
so etwas wie der Beckenbodenmuskulatur
die auch so im Alltag schon wenig
beansprucht wird neben den Muskeln wird
aber auch noch etwas anderes abgebaut
unsere Knochen Menschen die Mikro
Gravitation ausgesetzt sind verlieren
etwa ein bis zwei Prozent ihrer
Knochendichte für jeden Monat den sie im
All verbringen sobald hier ein
bestimmter Wert unterschritten wird
spricht man von Osteoporose bei der die
Knochen porös und brüchig werden solche
brüchigen Knochen erhöhen bei der Geburt
die Gefahr eines hüftbruchs so sehr
sogar dass damit natürliche Geburten im
All womöglich komplett ausgeschlossen
und nur noch Kaiserschnitte gemacht
werden müssten aber wie gesagt immerhin
löst das ja vielleicht unser
orientierungsproblem im Mutterleib dafür
trägt diese Art des medizinischen
Eingriffs noch einen sehr interessanten
Nebeneffekt mit sich der uns schon zum
vielleicht spannendsten Teil bringt
nämlich zu der Anatomie
eine Sache die nämlich bei einer
vaginalen Geburt passiert ist dass der
noch weiche Schädel des Kindes
zusammengedrückt wird weil dieser sonst
gar nicht durch den Geburtskanal passen
würde wenn wir diese Art des Gebärens
also hinter uns lassen würden könnte das
bedeuten dass astro-babys bei Geburt
größere Köpfe haben dazu kommt dass
durch die Umverteilung der Flüssigkeiten
im Körper sowieso das Gehirn anschwillt
und damit der Druck im Schädel steigt
beides zusammen könnte heißen dass
zukünftige space Generationen
tendenziell größere und rundere Köpfe
haben nach der Geburt könnte die
fehlende Schwerkraft die Entwicklung
eines Kindes negativ beeinflussen
Menschen die im All Waren werden ca 3%
größer als vorher es liegt daran dass
die Knorpel in den Zwischenräumen der
Knochen ohne die Schwerkraft nicht mehr
zusammengedrückt werden auch leiden sie
an Muskelschwund weil man in
Schwerelosigkeit die Muskeln eben kaum
noch benutzt soweit so bekannt wenn man
sich nun vorstellt ein Mensch würde sich
von Geburt an in Mikrogravitation
entwickeln während die Effekte
sicherlich noch viel ausgeprägter so ein
Mensch würde vermutlich nie auf der Erde
leben können ohne einen Rollstuhl zu
benutzen einfach weil die Schwachen
Gelenke gar nicht dafür ausgelegt sind
unter einem g richtig zu funktionieren
geht das so über Generationen hinweg
weiter könnte es sogar dazu kommen dass
Gene die für einen starken Körperbau
notwendig sind negative Mutationen
ansammeln die das Ausbilden von starken
Knochen Gelenken und Muskeln unmöglich
machen auch unsere Haut würde sich
vermutlich verändern erinnert ihr euch
noch an der jay-star die Kakerlake vom
Anfang bei ihren Nachkommen hat man
beobachtet dass sich ihre Panzer
wesentlich früher als üblich dunkel
gefärbt haben auch wir Menschen würden
ziemlich sicher unseren Melaningehalt in
der Haut anreichern um den natürlichen
Schutz gegen kosmische Strahlung zu
erhöhen das darf man sich allerdings
jetzt nicht so vorstellen wie wenn ich
mal den Malle Urlaub mache um mir eine
knackige Sommerbräune zuzulegen dieser
Prozess würde sich vermutlich über
mehrere Jahrhunderte ziehen in denen
sich dunklere Haut gegenüber hellere
Haut evolutiv durchsetzt einfach weil
dunklere Haut eben einen
Überlebensvorteil in unserem neuen
Lebensraum bietet indem sie e seltener
Hautkrebs bekommt das betrifft im
übrigen auch die Augenfarbe die
ebenfalls durch Melanin gesteuert wird
mit anderen Worten zukünftige space
Zivilisationen werden aufgrund des
evolutionsdrucks vermutlich immer
dunklere Haut und quasi nur noch braune
Augen haben und wer weiß vielleicht
entwickeln wir sogar ganz andere
Pigmente als Melanin die gegen andere
Arten von Strahlung helfen
[Musik]
die berühmte Zwillingsstudie der NASA
gibt weitere Hinweise darauf welche
anderen körperlichen Veränderungen auf
uns zukommen könnten falls ihr die
Studie noch nicht kennt von 2015 bis
2016 wurde Astronaut Scott Kelly für
insgesamt 340 Tage auf die ISS geschickt
sein eineiiger Zwilling mag Kelly
ebenfalls Astronaut blieb währenddessen
auf der Erde bei Scott im All wurden
deutlicher strahlungsinduzierte
Veränderungen des Erbguts erkannt auch
die schützenden Telomere der DNA wurden
angegriffen was zu schnelleren
Alterungen beiträgt Scott wie es
außerdem Wasserablagerungen auf die
unter anderem seine Sicht einschränken
und Entzündungserscheinungen sorgten
dafür dass die Wende manche seiner
Blutgefäße dicker wurden bei all diesen
Ergebnissen muss man allerdings auch
sagen dass die NASA selbst vorsichtig
ist hier einen direkten Zusammenhang
abzuleiten und viele dieser Effekte
haben sich nach Scots Rückkehr zur Erde
auch wieder zurückgebildet die Studie
ist eher eine Grundlage um Hypothesen
aufzustellen und in unterschiedliche
Richtungen weiter forschen zu können
aber trotzdem legen diese Ergebnisse
nahe dass wir uns definitiv auf einige
Umstellungen gefasst machen sollten wenn
wir irgendwann tatsächlich nicht nur 340
Tage sondern Jahre oder sogar ganze
Leben auf generationenschiffen und
anderen Planeten verbringen wollen
das ist er also unser menschlicher Alien
mindestens 5 cm größer als ein
durchschnittlicher menschling ein
dickerer Kopf leichte Knochen lange
Gliedmaßen dunkle Haut braune Augen und
hoffentlich viele viele evolutiv
hervorgebrachte Mechanismen die seinen
Körper und vor allem seine DNA irgendwie
vor kosmischer Strahlung schützen
wie gesagt das ist natürlich alles
nichts mehr als ein Gedankenexperiment
weil es in der Forschung nach wie vor
viel zu große Lücken gibt darüber haben
wir ausführlich im ersten Teil
gesprochen den er hier finden könnt und
vielleicht lassen sich einige dieser
Lücken auch gar nicht wirklich schließen
bis wir tatsächlich die ersten Menschen
zum Beispiel auf den Mars bringen bisher
haben wir es aber ja eigentlich immer
sehr gut geschafft uns an die
unterschiedlichsten Bedingungen
anzupassen entweder rein biologisch oder
mit Hilfe von Werkzeugen und
Innovationen und so bleibt die Hoffnung
dass wir auch diese Hürde als Menschheit
überwinden werden selbst wenn wir dann
ein klein wenig anders aussehen denkt
dran wenn ihr euch die clark-app
runterladet dann benutzt gerne den Code
Watson dazu könnt ihr den ersten Link
unten in der Videobeschreibung verwenden
oder ihr scannen mit eurem Handy den
QR-Code hier unten ein und wenn ihr drei
Versicherungen mit in die App reinbringt
dann könnt ihr euch Gutscheine im Wert
von bis zu 45 Euro sichern ansonsten wie
immer vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric